Reggie Miller the hall-of-famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst reg will be on the
call for the Jazz in the Nuggets
Thursday night at 10:30 Eastern along
with Allie LaForce and of course Kevin
Harlan doing play-by-play reg sorry I
realized that uncle drew did not get
nominated for any Academy of course
thoughts and prayers johnson prayer look
we were very disappointed obviously in
the uncle drew camp at least for makeup
we should have been nominated for for
those two to have three hours in that
makeup chair getting all those
prosthetics put on to the least
accounted for something I look like my
dad did a little you know acting for the
past month and a half they just don't
know what the what the Academy was
thinking okay you weren't wearing makeup
[Laughter]
look like I did an uncle drew
congratulations to my nemesis in Spike
Lee I hit him I told him look I know
we've always had our different
philosophies in terms of our basketball
human and who we root for but there is
no denying his eye for filmmaking and
it's been long overdue 20 years in my
estimation of him winning an Oscar I
thought he should have gotten one for
Malcolm X but that's just my personal
opinion but good though good things come
to those who wait so congratulations
spike yeah I think Malcolm X was maybe
the best movie that he ever did do the
right thing certainly got a lot of
headlines I don't know if America was
ready to embrace celebrate do the right
thing at the time
and that's when Driving Miss Daisy ended
up winning you know so you talk about
polar opposites of impact I think spike
did a mazing job would do the right
thing I just don't know if the Academy
was ready to embrace the movie at that
time
well they're embracing him now and kudos
for that I I really think his acceptance
speech was fabulous I'm not quite sure
about the purple suit well that was a
tribute to Prince that was status for
Prince I know I know but the huge wrong
point right LeBron James says that you
know these younger players have to have
a sense of urgency here here is LeBron
talking about excuses for the Lakers
then I'll get your opinion I know it's
gonna be very challenging just because
of the experience that you know the
roster had at that point in time you
know I knew it's gonna be challenging
from that sense but I felt like we could
still play you know better basketball
and we was doing that and obviously you
know sucks that my injury happened in
Zoe's injury happen and so many of our
Rangers have we a suspensions yet so you
know I'm so huge in like chemistry and
camaraderie and throughout the course of
the season through injuries and
suspensions that happen earlier so
whatever with that but the injuries have
no luck is taking a toll on our team are
you talking about camaraderie here he's
talking about these kids you know they
don't understand the urgency here how
would you feel if you're a teammate of
LeBrons right now that you were one of
the people who was gonna be traded and
now you know you don't have a sense of
urgency here he's right in the second
half of his comments about the injuries
because if you remember back to me the
injuries really derailed them because
when he went down on Christmas Day with
their groin injury the Lakers were
rolling and they were up what 18 20
points up to that injury and found a way
to hang on and beat the champs in their
building on Christmas Day but then he
misses 18 or 19 games and we see what
the LeBron young Lakers are without
their superstar but to his point you
know he wants these young guys to grow
up it was just a week and a half ten
days ago you know two weeks that all of
these young kids were on the trading
blocks and you've got to think others
like this how would you feel
you are playing with the best player in
their generation these young cats these
young guys Kuzma a ball Ingram they
probably had LeBron James poster while
they were younger they idolized this guy
now they get a chance to play with him
and you could say what you want it's
magic polenka running the team LeBron
because of his power is running the
Lakers I know people don't want to hear
that but he is yeah and all these guys
were on the auction block they were all
being shipped for Anthony Davis to New
Orleans so you're a 20 to 23 year old
guy and one moment we're on the chopping
block and we're going to be out of here
in the next moment
turn around you want to flame hard and
we've got to focus in and we've got to
do better so this is what these young
guys are going through generational type
best player in their generation these
young cat next I'm on the training block
and now now that it didn't go down you
want us to play hard 22 23 24 year old
they can't recover from this it's going
to be very difficult for them to hone in
they can do it because of the greatness
of LeBron but this is certainly going to
be a lot and they have to stay healthy
everyone has to stay healthy for this
what 22 23 game stretches getting ready
to come up for them do you think it's
better for the Lakers to make the
playoffs as the eighth team or mission
being the lottery missing being the
lottery
what good is making the 8 other than you
know boasting the Hall of Fame career
already of LeBron to me if they can find
a way to go on a stretch and get to the
center now we're talking because other
than Golden State in the West if I'm the
Lakers with LeBron and a healthy Devon
and Rondo playoff lawndale as I call
them I'll go against anyone in the West
other than that eighth seed and the
Golden State Warriors
because Denver is good and talented and
young and I love the Joker and Paul
Millsap now you get in Isiah Thomas back
I have absolutely loved
what the Nuggets are doing but I am not
scared of the Nuggets come playoff time
at all if I'm LeBron how did the Rockets
beat the Warriors without James Harden I
think because Kevin Harlan and myself we
called that huge overtime victory that
the Rockets had vs. Golden State by the
month and a half ago in Oracle when
James Harden hit that huge shot to
basically win it and the Warriors wanted
payback and then while I payback versus
James Harden I think when they found out
that James wasn't playing they thought
it was going to be a cakewalk and that's
why in this league no matter who you
play on any given night I don't care the
roster you can be beat now it's only one
game that wouldn't happen in the
seven-game series so I hope people are
like oh okay well the rocket go you got
to beat them four times you got to be
Golden State Warriors four times will
they have their lapses yes we've seen
that they almost lost coming back after
the break to Sacramento who in my
opinion is going to be a playoff team
and plays hard so on any given night
anyone can be beat but can you beat a
team four games that's the big question
James Harden got hit with a $25,000 fine
he criticized the officials scott foster
did you ever feel like you had an
official who was personally out to get
you I did not personally but I had my
run-ins with certain officials that I
was anytime I saw them on the road I
just tricked my head this wasn't going
to be a good night not personally for
myself maybe and/or for my team but for
them to make it so public and for you
know cp3
to say that he's had conversations with
the league office know about Scott
foster there's something that's
underlining here you know there's no way
you're gonna get them all in the room in
for James to come out and say that he
should never ever call a rockets game
again you're almost forcing the league's
hand on this I understand the fine
can't say that about official but he
should never ever call a game a rockets
gamer cat because if I'm the league the
next three rockets and Lakers game out
of would see Scott Foster just to shove
it down their throat you can't do that
you can't dictate who the officials are
finished system we're talking to Reggie
Miller he's got jazz Nuggets Thursday
night at 10:30 Eastern finished this
sentence my biggest concern about
lowering the draft age from 19 to 18 is
what it's great for design Williamson
and maybe our day barons of the world
but I believe you're gonna be getting
you know two and three star blue chip
players thinking that they're ready and
a team drafting them for the future and
they end up being bust and they end up
not having the opportunity I'm sure they
can go back later and get their
education but to play college basketball
my four years at UCLA were unbelievable
and that experience but times were
different back there in the 80s and
early 90s you know I was drafted in 87
and when you came out after your junior
year you would look like oh my god he's
coming out after his junior year he
really must be ready and now we know it
guys who are 17 or 18 who are much more
physically ready to play if you look at
Diane's body I mean he's got an NFL body
he could play in the NFL next year if he
wanted to so players are much more
physically ready to play in the NBA at
18
I just hope from parents and maybe
however you grew up and people around
you push you into that NBA Draft and
you're not quite ready you need a year
or two or three or god forbid all for
now you're almost frowned upon when you
go to college for three or four years
now now people think what is wrong
what's wrong with you why are you doing
that I needed my four years at UCLA
every summer playing with against the
Lakers in the pros that mentally got me
ready for 18 years professionally and if
it wasn't for those summers playing
against magic at Byron at Michael Cooper
and then basically brainwashing me on
how to become a professional basketball
player I don't know if I have a career
that I had if it wasn't for those four
years during the summer and those four
years at UCLA yeah I don't worry about
Zion Williamson and maybe RJ Barrett or
Cam radish made some of the other guys
who are being told because everybody
thinks they can play in the league you
know it that it just you get a lot of
people around you or gonna tell you that
and then you're gonna bypass maybe one
or two years in college which can get
you a little more ready for the league
maybe if it could be mentally you know
maturing to be even you know a lot of
them have the talent but you know you
have to go in there and be able to be
mature and handle being on the road and
having money and women throwing in
themselves I mean there's so much
involved in it I mean you got guys who
were 30 let alone 20 who have a hard
time dealing with this so I don't know
how many players are going to make this
jump out of high school I'm fine with it
you know I'm okay because we allow it in
all the other sports just about except
for the NFL and if you want to do it in
the bask in the NBA and that's what you
think your job trade is your skill then
fine go ahead you know I I wouldn't want
to stand in your way I understand why
the NBA doesn't want this because you
don't want about it you don't want to be
babysitting a bunch of 18 year olds 19
year olds here in the league will help
promote you know younger players being
able to go to a contract go up and down
you know from the big club it's almost
like a mica league system but also we
have to take into account is the finance
or restoring two of these younger kids
we don't know how they're growing up you
know a lot of these kids at times maybe
they come from a single-parent household
they're living paycheck to paycheck and
this is the best ways for them to you
know help their mom with her dad or the
grandmother out so I get it and I
understand it and I
can't fault them for that you know we
all can't grow up with a silver spoon
and have the financial capabilities of
not anybody
a lot of these kids don't and I
understand that's why the big outcry
outcry is about the NCAA is that these
kids can make money off their own like
this yes they can all I like this that's
what frustrates me about the Reg good to
talk to you and have fun Thursday night
jazz in the nuggets at 10:30 Eastern on
TNT Thank You reg Thank You wrench for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]